that's why that's why a lot of men are
afraid of getting married is because
like it's the cost is so great if you
get divorced like that's 20 of your
income that's a lot
so
but on the other hand you have like
legal protections as a girl
so it's like the the power shifts I'm
not saying it's right I'm just saying
that's how it is
I just think it's all about the examples
that you have of a marriage because
whenever I hear young people talk about
marriage it always sounds so down you
know I can't have no fun you know I
can't you know I've gotta give up
everything sometime in the future kind
of like oh yeah I will one day and
there's nothing wrong with being
submissive everybody all the women see
submissive a bad thing it's not a good
thing if you've got a man leading you
you know a marriage for a woman is great
she's got nothing to lose she can go
with nothing and she can come up with
everything so as far as I'm concerned
it's just like if you've got a good
example of marriage then you will see
marriage is a good thing
good examples of marriages you know
because my mom and dad were married I
got my mum and dad they're great I had
some old people that were married they
were great I remember I saw this woman
and she was like well spoken and she was
married to this man who had money and
they've been together for years and she
said I said how do you do it she said
compromise
she goes look at him look at him and she
was all well to do and he was there at
the bar drinking she goes if you know
and she'd actually helped him put his
money away to retire and marriage is a
great thing I think sometimes it's the
examples that people see around them
that tarnishes it to make it sound like
you're gonna lose everything because
there's people out there with marriages
that travel together have fun together
it's not about I'm gonna get married to
have children is I'm gonna get married
to be committed to this person then we
grow together and children will come do
you think just quickly that dot the
options that young people have now
has made that more difficult
too many too many options too many
options because there was a time where
you know it's in your local area you
know the the you go to church or
wherever you go and someone knows
somebody and now is worldwide well I
think the development of birth control
changed the game because there used to
be consequences so if you slept around
like you likely would get pregnant yeah
where then you could just sleep with
whoever you wanted
and so if you look at it's really
interesting if you look at graphs of
when the divorce rate started to go up
in the western world it's it's like the
same as when birth can like the number
of women on birth control Rolo tomasi
tweeted it if you want to go to his
Twitter it's actually really interesting
because men can't get pregnant yeah well
and then that gives that that's that's
why women
um push off marriage later and later it
gives them more time to lock down like
the high value guy and and that's the
other thing is like girls think they're
hotter than they are in 2022 because a
girl that's a four five six or seven can
sleep with a guy that's an eight nine or
ten but he would never be seen in public
with her he's just he's just sleeping
with her yeah and so that's what I'm
saying like because girls will think
their level is the guy that they're
sleeping with but it's not it's the guy
that you can get to commit to you so
that then you have girls that are
shooting down the guys that are actually
on their level
and so it leads this that's why it's 50
of women over 30 are single and
childless
then they try to go back to the guys
that were on their level yeah
yeah because that's why they're Left
Behind they're with someone of on their
level yeah yeah and I'm curious because
um you're a bit older so what like what
I'm just curious what are you you're
familiar with red pill it seems like do
you see that that older women get past
how do I put it they the guys they
rejected earlier will turn them down
later yes it happens a lot it happens
because you see the women and they think
oh no I remember there was a man and he
was um he didn't look younger I didn't
look all that nobody was after him he
became a Dustbin man you know nobody was
after him and they got old and he got
more handsome and he got a nice kind of
thing everybody's after him you know why
because they realized how much dust men
wanted how much they earned and then
when they were after him he didn't want
them he got some girl you know he was a
dustman I think he married like a lawyer
or something like that okay because she
saw his worth and it wasn't how much he
earned it was a good guy with potential
but nobody wanted nobody wanted him at
the time but now all those women now
that you know three children four
children why is a man gonna want to take
on you with two three four children you
know over 35 why
and what mistakes do you see did you see
younger girls make
when it comes to dating and what
mistakes maybe did you make and you
learned from
I'll get pregnant on the pill oh wow so
yeah first time pregnancy on the pill I
was on the pill and you never missed the
day I never missed it I was only on it
for about a month
okay yeah so and I got one child you
know because I learned my lesson but
nowadays it's like
it's too easy to go and get rid of a
child it's too easy to go and say
whether I'm going to get birth control
and I'm going to sleep with everyone
because I'm gonna I'm not going to get
pregnant it's not going to bother me but
every what the young people don't
realize every time they sleep with a man
you're giving away a bit of yourself
so by the time you preach 35 there's
hardly anything left you because you've
given it away to all these people and
they don't realize that men can sleep
with women it don't mean nothing to them
but women sleep with men and it's
emotional and every time you sleep with
a man
you give away a bit of yourself and
that's what the young people don't
realize that they're just giving
themselves away Bit by Bit by Bit do you
think women have gotten better or worse
over time worse why because they just
think they're all that
they're independent they've got their
own money they can do what they like
they don't need men and then when they
need them and the men don't want them
but they do need men they just don't
realize it yet why does a woman need a
man that's what I mean they just don't
realize it yet because you try surviving
on your own without a man you cannot
wake up in the morning and go through
your whole day without having to rely on
a man for something like what
by everything around us whether you go
you get your picture or wherever you go
and you get the bus whether you the the
the the clothes that you wear in the
shop the designer you cannot get through
life without a man man built the world
like they they do all of the hard jobs
in society everything that makes the
infrastructure run I'm not saying we
don't need men that's not my view at all
but I just feel like
this is what this is like that term left
over I feel like the things you're
saying and the over Reliance on men
that's what perpetuates that view
because it makes it seem like a woman
literally can't survive without a man
and I feel like you're linking that like
one thing you mentioned earlier you said
that there's a link between divorce
rates and um when women were able to get
access to birth control and I feel like
in terms of marriage like when you're
when you're equating marriage with
that's when a woman's gonna have kids
and she's gonna take some of the man's
income in that sense I feel like
um I've lost my point now I forgot what
I said today a lot of I feel like
there's a lot of feelings is there any
do you come from a place of logic or is
this all feeling
what do you think his feeling so what do
you think is feeling no because you say
I feel like I feel like I feel like so I
was just wondering if you're saying that
I do want me to say no no I don't know
I'm is it all feeling if you tell me
your feeling then I don't think it's
feeling this is what I mean I feel like
women have what do you want me to say
yeah okay okay so
um yeah from what you said about divorce
rates and birth control I feel like
that's where women have gained